bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 23 septembre avec
la crise sanitaire la société
protectrice des animaux n'a pas pu
maintenir ses traditionnelles portes
ouvertes
elle a donc lancé le 14 septembre
dernier le mois de l'adoption qui court
jusqu'au 4 octobre une manière de
compenser la hausse des abandons
notre invité guillaume sanchez directeur
général de la spa nous en parlera dans
un instant installé en france elle n'en
n'oublient pas leur devoir de citoyenne
américaine
nous avons rencontré des expatriés dans
les yvelines elles vont voter par
correspondance pour élire le prochain
président des états unis
elle témoigne le paris saint germain et
l'opérateur bio d'ifd créé par le
département des yvelines est celui des
hauts-de-seine ont signé une convention
sur la compensation environnementale
pour la construction de nouveaux centres
d'entraînement à poissy est aussi une
bonne nouvelle
le cabaret du bout des pré situé à
cerner la ville va enfin rouvrir ses
portes l'équipe attend cela avec
impatience
et dans l'actualité du jour nous
accueillons guillaume sanchez
vous êtes le directeur de la spa bonsoir
d'abord est bienvenue bonjour madame
monsieur bonsoir et jusqu'au 4 octobre
la société protectrice des animaux donc
la spa organise le mois de l'adoption
cet événement remplacent les
traditionnelles portes ouvertes
organisées deux fois par an mais
évidemment annulé avec la crise
sanitaire pour la protection de vos
équipes des 62 refuge et maison spa de
france
nous y reviendrons dans un instant
d'abord aujourd'hui guillaume sanchez
qu'elle est un petit peu l'état des
lieux la spa y at il une augmentation
des abandons en général en france donc
il ya eu une augmentation il ya une
augmentation concernant les chats au
mois d'août et on est dans un esprit
très combatif à la rentrée puisque
malheureusement constate de plus en plus
de chiens qui nous sont abandonnés
directement malgré une belle seconde
place et justement grégory canale et
astrid bergère se sont rendus à orgeval
l'un des trois refuges de la spa dans
les yvelines
aux côtés de plaisir et d'ermeux ray qui
accueille les futurs adoptants adopter
un animal beaucoup en rêvent
dans le cadre du mois de l'adoption les
équipes de la spa sont mobilisés pour
accueillir les futurs adoptants et pour
certaines familles qui souhaitent un
animal aller dans un refuge est une
évidence trouve que c'est important il
ya des chiens qui sont engagés autant
leur donner leur chance plutôt qu'à
aller voir directement les éleveurs et
prendront un show mais adopter un animal
est une décision qui doit être mûrement
réfléchie pour éviter les abandons
l'adoption doit être responsable pour
faire vraiment attention il faut
réfléchir faut penser à tout faut penser
au plan b pour les vacances france et a
plein de choses à penser au budget que
ça représente parce que c'est pas non
plus
naudin c'est pas juste un paquet de
croquettes tous les mois donc il faut
vraiment bien réfléchir avant d adopter
et donc je pense que nous on est bon la
spa constate une baisse des abandons de
chiens de 14%
malheureusement la situation est bien
différente pour les chats on a beaucoup
de chatons que ce qui est dû au fait que
les stérilisations n'ont pas pu avoir
lieu pendant tout le confinement donc il
ya une dérive et de chatons en as
tous les jours on a des appels pour des
chatons de trouver malheureusement n'est
pas en capacité de tous les accueillir
et on manque cruellement de famille
relaie aussi pour pouvoir les accueillir
or refuge face à ce nombre croissant de
chats abandonnés
la spa un message clair faites
stériliser vos animaux quoi fait les
stériliser parce que là c'est une
catastrophe au niveau des chatons c'est
vraiment c'est pareil au niveau national
quoi on a tous été débordé par par les
arrivées de chatons qui sont en plus
malade la plupart au total la spa espère
trouver grâce à ce mois de l'adoption
3300 famille on l'a entendu à l'instant
14% donc de baisse d'abord dont des
chiens pourquoi ces différences entre
les chiens et les chats guillaume
sanchez
déjà s'il ya une tendance nationale
depuis quelques années où on constate
nous dans nos refuges une stabilisation
du nombre de chiens est en revanche une
explosion du nombre de chats et je
rejoins tout à fait ce que disent les
collègues d'orgeval
c'est à dire que on a un problème
stérilisation et de prolifération des
chats qui finalement dès lors qu'ils ne
sont pas stérilisés ont tendance à
vagabonder et nous récupérons n'est
vraiment j'irai au bout de la chaîne
entre des adoptions qui ont lieu suite
au bon coin qui sont pas réfléchies les
abandonnés ou un nombre de charges on
est juste énorme qui fait qu on paie de
lui même avec trois manches longues
on en perd un certain nombre il n'a
obligé de faire appel à des familles
relève ce bébé il s'agit de biberonner
absolument toutes les nuits et qu'en est
il des nac donc je le rappelle les
nouveaux animaux de compagnie donc dans
les nac il y a les lapins les
chinchillas les hamsters qu'en est il du
coup pour les nac alors sur les nac
on a on a une augmentation régulière ce
que c'est malheureusement des animaux de
compagnie qui sont achetés comme des
objets en animalerie les gens les
assiettes sur des coups de coeur et
malheureusement on a une faible prise de
conscience le seul point positif c'est
qu'en revanche des gens les trouvent et
ont conscience qu'il faut les ramener
dans un refuge et donc on les met à
l'adoption
que ce soit des chinchillas que ce soit
lapin notamment on en reçoit un certain
nombre monte leed un certain nombre de
manière à éviter la reproduction mais on
est sur une progression assez régulière
de 5 à 10% par an comme on parle de
baffe forcément c'est très des chiffres
dans l'absolu assez assez faible mais
maintenant par an sur les 43 mille
animaux
on a plus de linac qui sont adaptés
parents de la petite souris aux hamsters
okocha roanne etc
donc on l'a bien compris ce mois de
l'adoption qui je le rappelle remplacent
les traditionnelles journées portes
ouvertes vous recherchez 3300 famille en
france c'est bien ça en fait on propose
à 3300 personnes 3300 famille pardon
d'agrandir leur famille de faire la
place à un nouvel animal chez eux et et
notamment de mon ami 7700 chat et 1340
chien voyez il ya vraiment quoi les plus
une centaine de nac ya de quoi
satisfaire absolument l'envi d'agrandir
sa famille pour tous quel que soit le
profil des personnes n'est vraiment avec
l' envie de battre tout simplement et
c'est très bien dit dans le reportage
d'ouvrir tout simplement un foyer
d'offrir un foyer à ces animaux qui
n'attendent que ça est plutôt qu'aller
dans une animalerie mme chez un éleveur
là vous trouverez chez nous des animaux
qui finalement n'ont que leur coeur à
offrir et justement si on veut sauter le
pas pour adopter du coup une adoption
responsables comment fait-on à la espère
déjà fait confiance aux professionnels
vous allez trouver dans les différents
refuges ou maison sp a qui vont ont
l'habitude de vous conseiller
même si parfois ça peut sembler étonnant
dû questionner sur vos habitudes de vie
est ce que vous avez comment combien de
fois vous prévoyez le sortir d'ouvrir
vers l'extérieur quels types d'habitats
vous proposer de manière ils placent
leurs animaux et l'objectif c'est plutôt
parfois vous orienter vers un autre type
d'animal vers un autre type de
comportement qui correspondra le mieux
possible
on est parfois surpris d'avoir d'avoir
des gens qui vivent dans un petit espace
qui prévoit de laisser un chien 16h tout
seul vouloir impérativement ont par
exemple un labrador ou
[Musique]
et merci pour toutes ces précisions
guillaume sanchez je le rappelle un
animal évidemment n'est pas sans jouer
c'est un être vivant il faut en prendre
soin l'adoption est donc un acte
réfléchi on l'a bien compris merci
encore guillaume sanchez
merci beaucoup à vous nous avoir fait de
la place yonnais de gâteaux merci dans
l'actualité également depuis le début de
la crise de coved 19 près de quarante
mille entreprises et indépendants ont
été aidés par la région ile de france
ces aides ont permis à 95% des
entreprises de traverser cette période
difficile
bilan dans les yvelines par marie
pannetrat et milani poké cette
entreprise de signalétique dans le btp a
perdu près de 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires pendant le confinement mais
elle a survécu grâce à ses fonds propres
et en trouvant de nouveaux clients
ces machines ont produit des plaques de
protection en plexiglas des panneaux sur
le co vide alors à l'époque pas besoin
d'être financière aujourd'hui par
précaution elle a tout de même demandé
le prêt garanti par l'état suite à une
réunion que nous avons eue avec d'autres
experts comptables
là il nous a proposé de faire la demande
pour m voilà cet apport financier de
côté au cas où voilà le problème de
pandémie reviennent depuis la
réouverture des chantiers l'entreprise
d'une quinzaine de salariés repris son
activité traditionnelle pour le mois de
septembre elle a réussi à récupérer son
chiffre d'affaires de 2019 et pense même
pouvoir l'augmenter mais toutes les
petites entreprises n'ont pas eu cette
chance la région ile de france a mis en
place plusieurs z le fond relance le pm
relance mais aussi le fourgon nous avons
accordé 200 millions de prêts nous
allons leur est abondée c'est la bpi la
banque publique d'investissement qui
gère les demandes de prêts et oui on en
a encore besoin les entreprises ont
encore besoin de s'endetter pour
investir à lacets pme on ne cache pas
son inquiétude de l'avenir la
confédération compte plus de 600
adhérents
c'est la grosse difficulté du moment
c'est l'incertitude c'est de pas savoir
ce que de quoi demain sera fait subir
une fermeture pendant un mois
je pense que la majorité des structures
arrive à résister à ça puisqu'on sait
contient des murs et quand il une fin on
y arrive ce qui est le plus dur pour
nous c'est de pas savoir ni quand ni
combien de temps ça va durer
depuis le début de la crise qu vit près
de quarante mille entreprises et
indépendants ont été aidés par la région
ile de france
j - 41 avant l'élection présidentielle
aux états unis pour les américains
vivent à l'étranger
le scrutin a déjà commencé un vote par
correspondance avec différentes
procédures en fonction de l'état c'est
le cas pour deux yvelinoise
franco-américaine et leurs enfants qui
vivent à d'avron et mareil sur mauldre
un reportage de nicolas landry c'est un
grand moment pour tracy et maya sa fille
de 18 ans elles viennent de recevoir
leurs bulletins de vote pour participer
à l'élection présidentielle aux états
unis pour ses deux yvelinoise pas besoin
d'attendre le 3 novembre prochain elles
vont voter par correspondance
cette année c'était absolument
primordial d'être sûr d'avoir
pouvoir voter à à temps pour les
élections du coup je suis enregistré en
ligne et aussi j'ai téléphoné à mieux
peut-être sûr que j'étais j'allais
recevoir un bulletin de vote pour new
york le bulletin est envoyé par la poste
par courrier par email par fax ou sur un
site internet
chacun des 50 états à son propre système
de vote par correspondance est mis et
son fils lucas vote en floride
ils ont le choix entre l'envoi dans une
enveloppe ou la possibilité de fax et
les documents aient voté pour la
première fois par fax
d'habitude je cochais mon bulletin et je
les mettais dans deux enveloppes mais
cette année il ya tellement de problèmes
avec la poste aux états unis que je n'ai
pas osé faire ça pour maya et lucas
c'est la première participation à une
élection présidentielle ils ont un
regard particulier sur leur pays
d'origine
je trouve que le pays va vers parra
catastrophe et j'en suis plus du tout
fier je tue que tous les ans tout casser
à sa politique et ses actions et sa
mentalité est plus tout celle que je que
je partage les gens ne sont pas censés
être raciste ne sont pas censés être
tout ce qui ce qui se passe là en ce
moment les la police qui fait des
bavures du côté de tracy et amy ce
scrutin est essentiel même s'il rappelle
le souvenir de la dernière élection
surprise en 2016 lg très nerveuse en
fait les gens me demandent alors qu'est
ce que vous pensez je préfère ne pas lui
dire il y a quelques années je dis non
je pense comme un maire de et va passer
non et puis là je dis non
maintenant je n'ai plus rien j'ai croise
les doigts comme tout le monde je pense
que c'est une vote existentielle celle à
de futurs l'avenir de la démocratie
américaine est là cette fois ci je pense
qu'on pourrait basculer dans
l'autocratie et c'est absolument
affolants pour voter de l'étranger les
citoyens américains doivent s'inscrire
sur ce site internet plus de 6 millions
de personnes sont concernées dans le
monde ce matin à versailles avait lieu
pardon ce mardi 22 septembre avait lieu
à versailles la signature de la
convention de compensation
environnementales entre le paris
saint-germain et l'opérateur public
territorial bio dit
pour la construction du nouveau centre
d'entraînement de poissy un engagement
du club parisien à hauteur de 4,2
millions d'euros sur les 30 prochaines
années dont 3,7 millions d'euros
directement dédiés à biot dif
les détails de cet accord au micro de
bixente mais rien 110 tebbane avec
l'interview express du directeur
exécutif du psg jean claude blanc cet
engagement marque le fait de bloquer des
terrains à l'extérieur du site pour
environ une vingtaine d'hectares
ainsi qu'une trentaine d'hectares sur le
site lui-même pour compenser les
constructions qui vont se dérouler sur
le centre d'entraînement pour sa
création
l'objectif est de dédier des zones donc
à l'extérieur du site mais aussi sur le
site à la biodiversité à eau pour
garantir qu'un certain nombre d'espèces
faune et flore vont pouvoir continuer à
se développer sur le site ou proches du
site dans les yvelines
c'est donc un engagement de 30 ans qui
se régularise ce soir entre le paris
saint-germain et bio d'ifd pour la
gestion pour l'identification d'abord
puis la gestion pendant trente ans de
ces différentes nous avons aussi
d'autres sites qui ont été identifiés
grâce à la région ile de france et qui
seront gérés par par l'organe de la
région ile de france dédié à gérer ces
sites
la totalité de ces deux éléments ce qui
composera au total total de 54 ha 20
hectares en dehors 24 hectares en dehors
du site et 30 hectares sur le site pour
la première fois depuis le confinement
le cabaret du bout des prêts rouvre ses
portes ce week end
pour l'occasion la troupe jouera un
spectacle un peu modifiée de comédien en
moins sur scène et une bande-son
davantage inspirés des années 60
reportage d'astrid bergère et marie
pannetrat après environ six mois de
fermeture cet enfant le retour sur les
planches
un soulagement pour les comédiens du
cabaret du bout des prêts ce samedi 26
septembre
c'est l'ouverture le spectacle raconte
l'histoire de mario un pizzaïolo qui
tombe amoureux de l'allée danseuse au
cabaret ça faisait vraiment du bien sûr
dépenses et puis d'avoir encore le
contact avec tous les copains danseurs
danseuses qui nous a tellement manqué là
c'est génial puis pour la scène c'est un
peu une drogue donc voila quand on en a
plu pendant six mois c'est un peu
compliqué la troupe a appris début
septembre la date de réouverture ce qui
bloquait les conditions de jeu sur scène
distanciation social masques et nombre
de comédiens sur les planches
tout était compliqué à mettre en place
le spectacle a été modifié depuis la
saison dernière avec plus de chansons
des années 60
ici sans toi je suis encore
[Musique]
j'étais impatient en tout cas après
toute cette période de pouvoir pouvoir
revenir ici et et se remettre au boulot
oui c'était remis au boulot avant
télétravail mais de deux se remettant en
voulons encore une fois face aux gens
avec eux pour les faire travailler les
faire les faire évoluer
est-ce qu'ils puissent se magnifier eux
mêmes dans cette pièce
le spectacle sera en représentation
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 une année
particulière car le cabaret il fêtera
ses vices comme chaque semaine la parole
est donnée aux programmateurs des salles
de cinéma saint-quentinoise cette
semaine bertrand pigné de l'espace
philippe noiret hockey sous bois nous
parle de deux films les choses qu'on dit
les choses qu'on fait est énorme au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude dans
les salles de l'espace philippe noiret
cette semaine telle est évidemment mais
deux films français surtout puisqu'il
faut aussi parler de la production
hexagonale qui kir et arrive dans les
salles et qui prend le risque de revenir
dans les salles
alors que le public a encore du mal à y
revenir
je vous parlais de deux films un film
qui s'appelle les choses qu'on dit les
choses qu'on fait un film d'amour une
grande fresque de deux heures d'amour
d'histoire d'amour de gens qui se
raconte des histoires d'amour quelque
chose de très léger de très beaux avec
camélia jordana et vincent macaigne et
niels schneider
un film de emmanuel mouret une comédie
romantique qui je pense pourra plaire
beaucoup de monde
garçons comme filles puisque voilà c'est
des choses très touchante
un deuxième film aussi qui est un peu un
coup de coeur qui s'appelle énorme
l'histoire d'un homme qui
devient enceintes en même temps que sa
femme qu'il a mis enceinte par
forfanterie un film de sophie letourneur
qui est une réalisatrice trop peu
présente sur nos écrans et avec jonathan
cohen et marina foïs deux comédies donc
une romantique une plus délirantes deux
choses à aller voir à l'espace philippe
noiret dès cette semaine
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de nous
avoir suivis mais juste avant de
refermer cette édition un petit clin
d'oeil à un grand acteur il ya 50 ans
jour pour jour le 23 septembre 1970
andré raimbourg dit bourvil nous
quittait à l'âge de 53 ans des suites
d'un cancer connu notamment pour ses
rôles dans le corniaud la traversée de
paris ou encore la grande vadrouille
il est repose hamon en ville dans les
yvelines on se quitte sur cet extrait
non je ne me souviens plus du nom d'une
balle perdue
ce dont je me souviens c'est de ces
amoureux qui ne regardaient rien autour
de l'étang de lumière avec eux dans la
rue alors la belle affaire
le nom des balles perdues non je ne me
souviens plus du nom du bal perdu ce
dont je me souviens c'est qu'on était
heureux les yeux au fond des yeux
c'était bon
[Musique]